okay the time being
10:05 we'll get going uh today um as you
know from the schedule we've got uh six
bills that we're going to uh put through
a work session today this morning
starting at 10: and then this afternoon
starting at 1 we'll have an exec session
and um we'll go through uh many of those
there's a couple that we won't be
exacting but we'll talk about that when
we get there for now we'll focus on the
work session I guess I don't have
a
g okay I'm going to open the work
session on HB
and uh representative Aly I I assume you
want to say a word or
two
two yes um HB
1492 um thank you gets us back a lot of
money that is it's about 6% of the
revenue from LA from last year from
FY uh
23 um and we really can't afford to lose
any more Revenue uh because we're not
going to have uh the Surplus money
coming in from the feds anymore and
we've been spending that Surplus money
at a very fast rate it seems to me so
that it wouldn't be available to fall
back on a lot of it is also going to I
saw a graphic the other day that says
that of the um money from the
um the third stimulus package
on we are about a year Year from closure
of being able to use that money a third
of it has not been appropriated at all a
third of it has been appropriated and
not been spent
yet so we're not doing very well on
keeping that Surplus somehow to to use
in in
future uh times on the other thing that
I think is really important is that I
don't know yet I don't know if Keen
knows uh
when the
uh the exemptions for the interest in
dividends tax were last
changed it's more than 30 years at this
point and on the inflation has been
quite significant since then uh we have
a lot of people paying who are paying
teeny amounts that give us almost no
money and uh um really can't afford that
teeny amount so um the bill also triples
the
exemptions um to restore it to something
like what it was for a very long
time u a tax on unearned
income that
uh is mostly paid by extremely wealthy
people and Wealthy
businesses and um a number a fair number
of those wealthy people are not paying
any
other uh tax in our state except for uh
consumption of meals rooms and
tobacco
and buying
liquor so thank
you comments questions
thoughts representative
PL yes representative Aly wasn't here
yesterday when I uh discussed the omnus
tax cut Bill and said this is not the
year to discuss any tax cuts so should
be done during a budget year we brought
a $100 million in Surplus but that could
disappear in a hurry uh and the quidd
proquo in my mind was we don't talk
about tax increases either and and uh so
maybe all of this could be deferred till
next year and uh we we the other point
arguing politely against you
representative Aly is that we say we're
an income tax free and that's clearly an
income tax on the
elderly
represent elme yes uh it is a tax on
unearned income at the risk of
encouraging some
Republicans uh to do something about it
we have a capital gains tax inside the
BPT and we have a Earned Income Tax in
the
bet they're just a little bit more in
direct
indirect but there is a reason that
um a lot of states and uh the country
went to an income tax in the early 20th
century which is still um in effect that
it is pretty
impossible to run a modern government
with the services that are most of our
population insists we need to
have without something like that and
something like that
was the interest in dividends tax and
the BET and the
BPT and
um they are perhaps less efficient at
um discriminating how much uh each
person can afford to pay which is what
is in the
Constitution uh that those all of us who
can afford to pay something should be
paying something and all of us who can
afford to pay more should be paying more
of the
burden uh
so
um we depend a great deal in this this
state as do other states uh
on the labor from people who are towards
the bottom of the income scale and the
more
we keep them
from Health Access the more we keep them
from Child Care access or we keep them
from housing
access uh the less of them we're going
to have in this state to keep
our
um our state as healthy and as beautiful
as it is now
so comments questions
thoughts representative spillsbury
yes excuse me thank you Mr chairman now
preface my comment by saying I do not
pay the interest in dividends tax but I
think one of its flaws and it becomes
accentuated when you raise the
minimum is that it rests on a very small
percentage of our
population and so much so as you narrow
that pool that I think it even raises
constitutional issues of uh being
equitably
applied representative Aly thank you um
this is something I've been looking at
very carefully with the business taxes
too as we rais the exemptions that they
not
become a larger part of the tax taxing
population taxed population than um they
were over the long term
before and actually when this tax was
created it was a wealth
tax that the state put in because it was
on interest and from
banking from your bank
accounts and very few people in
1912 had bank
accounts so it was pretty it was pretty
much a wealth tax and it has migrated
over the years
to the range of investment results that
people have and the range of of
uh um people that were paying it and
when we do
not move with inflation on
exemptions and I'm one of the ones
responsible for not moving over the last
25 years uh
because the then head of Dr told us that
uh half of the money was coming from
poor elderly people so we were afraid to
do
anything to the tax uh as we know now
that is not true we have the
triangles
um but as we
if we when we do not move with
inflation we are
taxing
uh less uh more people than we were
taxing before we are bringing bringing
the the tax down to levels where people
really can't afford it by the way I do
pay interest in dividends
tax
okay yes representative Southworth uh
thank you Mr chairman I do think this is
a reasonable way to uh collect Revenue I
have paid it a couple of times and my
mom pays it I think you need to
contribute to your state for all the
different services and things that a
state needs um to succeed and do well in
the future I think for someone with a
100,000 in interest and dividends which
probably is a multi-million
um 4,000 to the state is not um
unreasonable and I think for a
billionaire to pay 40,000 to the state
uh again uh it's not an unreasonable
plan in my
opinion uh representative ORS thank you
Mr chair so uh just a couple thoughts
one you mentioned the tax uh that
started in the early 20th century that
originally was set at I think 34,000 and
and my concern is what we've seen in
history is that that 34,000 where the
tax started to avoid the poor paying tax
eventually came down to where everybody
paid the
tax and with the in and D tax I don't
know
that if we eliminate it would we bring
big money people into the state to
invest maybe maybe not uh but one thing
one thing for sure and you said it is
that if if it were to stay I think the
bar should be raised so as Tom said it's
high enough so that people that aren't
millionaires or billionaires aren't
paying that
tax yes representa
please thank you Mr chair
um I appreciate all the
comments that have been made um
representative spillsbury
raised the question of inequity and I
feel I'm 49 I think I'm by far the
second
youngest um at the table so I've grown
up in an economy that is different um
than people who are you know 20 or 30
years older than me so the economy that
I'm living in and that I've been working
in and trying to raise money in is
different than
that of people who are now in
retirement and so I think that we need
to think about the generations who are
not maybe represented at this table and
when we talk about
inequity it I think we've we've gone so
far that now we're wondering if we're
inequitably taxing the rich and the
reason that there's so much wealthier is
because of inequity so I feel like we're
we're like we've created this huge gap
between the and have not and then we're
asking ourselves if it's fair to tax the
rich so we've gone to this point where
it's it's a bit illogical so yes wealthy
people should pay taxes I don't think
that they should not have to pay taxes I
pay
taxes uh so if people want to move to
the
state they should assume they have to
pay taxes otherwise it's just a race to
the bottom right and I feel like we're
doing that internationally we're doing
it state to state people have to pay
taxes otherwise we have no State
services and I hear um friends and
neighbors complain because they can't
hire a carpenter right and it's like
well we need to have policies in the
state where families can't afford to
live here and we should legislate for
families who live in New
Hampshire and not just for rich people
that we hope one day will move to New
Hampshire because of our policies so I
hope that we will consider not only rich
people we would like to invite to move
to New Hampshire but the families that
live here now and frankly that every
year if they have the means ask
themselves like my family does can we
stay here or does is this state telling
us to move away cuz when we cut taxes on
indd and there is no relief in sight for
property taxpayers it is the message
seems crystal clear to me who do we want
to invite to our state I understand it
would be great to have a bunch of rich
people live here but they're not going
to be your Carpenters right they're not
going to be your nurses they're not
going to be your caretakers as we
continue to get older in the state we're
going to need more of those workers so I
hope that we will think about ways to
make everyone pay their Fair share
because I feel like this bill is not
responding to why our constituents sent
us here they want everyone to contribute
their fair share and this is frankly I
feel like it's asking the wealthy to
contribute too little frankly thank
you yes represent elberger thank you Mr
chairman I would like to agree with my
colleague from namester despite the fact
that I'm the generation above you
uh the percentage of taxes that the
wealthy have paid has dropped hugely for
the last 100 years or so uh I represent
nasua we I have spoken to people who are
leaving the state because they can't
afford to live here the people that we
want to do our Lawns to be the
caregivers to be the weight staff in
restaurants to be our mechanics they
can't afford to live here and if the
services that we provide diminish and
the tax burden falls disproportionately
on them which I believe it does then we
can have all our
wealthy in
migrants but there's not going to be
anybody to help take care of them I a
society needs to have a broad range of
people in it to function well that's
genders that's ethnicities that's
religions all of those bits and economic
status and if we are catering only to
the wealthy then we're not going to
survive as a
state representative Aly yeah just one
more thing about these investors moving
in investors move in with investment
portfolios that uh are are very widely
based usually
across um locations across uh
regions uh cross
countries and
um the when you're moving in I
spent um about eight years while both my
both of my parents were were still able
uh and an all Rich old folks home in
north of of hover uh that
contained uh and eating dinner with
quite a few people that had moved into
the
state
and none of them were setting up new
firms or setting up new firms or
investing in something local in
particular they are coming coming in
because and one of them actually um was
surprised at dinner when I pointed out
that we had a 5% income tax interest and
dividends tax that is and she hadn't
heard about that yet because they hadn't
been didn't have a program at that point
to tell people moving in by the
way but
on I don't believe that that um this is
really an important impact because there
are a lot of places around us that
have higher tax loads than we do and
charge them to the upper class as well
as everybody else um and
they
um Bill
hatch informed me of of this he was on
finance until recently uh but he used to
uh put to put C curtains and rugs and
carpets uh and uh other things into um
major houses and major um hotels in the
North
country and he had clients that built uh
homes in the unincorporated territories
where there was no tax of any kind going
going on on that lived in New York
City and they came once a year to New
Hampshire to say here I am and they said
they were citizens of New Hampshire to
New
York and paid our uh interest in
dividends tax he was a little worried
that the interest in dividends tax would
uh
would uh go down if this scam was
discovered he didn't have any strong
evidence of this by the way but this was
not what he was thinking um but they
were happy to come to New Hampshire for
one day a year they weren't investing
anything except you were paying for our
interest in dividends tax
yes um representative Malloy thank you
Mr
chairman this just occurred to me as I'm
today uh I moved here from Iowa 20 some
years
ago and then that
state obviously paid a federal income
tax we also paid a state income tax and
property taxes and sales taxes I moved
out here and I thought how do we run
this
place uh but in
Iowa the first form we filled out was
our state income tax form that was more
complicated and with that state income
tax form the result of that you could
deduct that state your state income
taxes off the
fit uh I don't know if that's we've
talked about that even discuss that or
see an option here to um do something
like that to if somebody's paying an
interest in dividends tax is there a way
to deduct that from the uh your federal
your federal
form thank
you uh representative
Ames well um I'm glad we're having this
discussion um my
larger view
of of um New Hampshire's tax
system is first that it has historically
been
um
reliable because it has had it has drawn
from many different tax revenue sources
not just taxes uh Lottery and uh liquor
are examples of how it's uh um how the
bucket is filled up is not just taxes
but uh that diversity of uh source of
Revenue has been a strength of New
Hampshire so Point number one is taking
away a major Revenue Source um
weakens the state's ability to weather
the various storms that
come our way um so I think it's a
serious mistake to undo this tax and I
should have said that I do pay indd tax
or at least have until this change goes
through I'm one of the small taxpayers
that would benefit from this um I'm I'm
getting I well I'll say it I'm
old um I'm not just getting old but I'm
old
and U and thus uh certainly more on the
fixed income side than anything else and
so um this uh uh tax is relevant to my
situation um but uh I believe in it I
believe that we all should pay according
to our ability that's in the
Constitution um we also should have a
tax structure that's reasonable and
proportional that too is in the
Constitution and as we uh peel away
taxes that reach those at the upper end
of uh both wealth and
income um we
um we peel away
our adherence to that concept of
reasonable and proportional when we look
at the whole and I think we should start
looking at the whole is this whole thing
reasonable and proportional and if you
do do that then we've got many studies
that say no no the whole is not
reasonable and proportional it's far
from it in fact we are one of the um
most regressive states in the country on
uh how we on the results of our various
taxes and their impact on people the uh
it is the
people at the lowest end that are paying
the highest proportion of
their income and it's the people at the
well it's really resources and income
property tax is part of that and uh then
it's the people at the highest end who
are paying the lowest proportion so it's
exactly opposite of where we ought to be
but um and taking away this tax just
undermines that um so I I wel welcome
representative aly's effort to
resurrect this tax in a better form with
increased exemptions making it uh
more
um
more responsive to the situation of the
lowincome low interest and dividend
income um
taxpayers and so I I wish we could go
forward with this I'm a realist and uh I
I know that uh there are various
barriers to that so if uh if we can't go
forward with it I deeply regret that uh
we can't as a legislature or as a
committee um reach a consensus to go
forward I can understand the argument
representative
flet has made PL sorry has made um
and uh that uh this is not a tax year
I've made that argument myself in other
contexts and uh and maybe that's what we
have to do it just means uh uh kicking
the can down the road and and and
placing the state in a situation which
in which it will be very vulnerable to
abrupt changes or unexpected changes in
the state or national
economy
thank you thank you um anybody yes
represent elberger one more quick piece
of information as we talk about low
taxes here people generally avoid adding
property taxes into the tax burden so I
did my totally unscientific research
just now um house that I lived in in L
Massachusetts is currently valued at
$7,000
$700,000 and the taxes are $4,000
a year my house in nashwa is uh
currently valued at about
5.7 five
$570,000 and the taxes are
8.2 $8,200 so more than twice the taxes
on my current house which is about
uh uh 20% lower in
value I mean to that point it is true
that New Hampshire has High property
taxes however the to study after study
the total tax burden were one of the
lowest tax burden States um we can
certainly we certainly have
disagreements on how that tax burden
should be distributed but in in general
you know I I don't dispute your numbers
but I think in general um you look at
study after study New Hampshire is one
of the lowest tax burden States and and
that may be the point is that the
property tax is a regressive tax it is
flat rate regard regard less of your
income and folks who are not living in
large houses and not making a lot of
money are paying the same rate on their
smaller Homes at lower
salaries uh represent erery thank you Mr
chair and to the comment that was just
made um yes it's a flat rate our
constitution calls for an equitable and
proportional which means that everyone
pays at the same rate within the same
class if you're a property owner you pay
the same rate across the board within
your class of property be it a um single
family or a multiple family or
commercial property depending upon how
that goes
which to address the issue of being
regressive a property tax is the only
tax that every person in the state pays
whether you're a property owner or
you're a
rental you were paying into that
property tax B it burden it is the only
tax that everybody participates
in which makes it one of the most
egalitarian taxing
systems ever devised because everyone
happens to that I would comment that
taking from some to give to others
sounds suspiciously like uh a 19th
century
German uh economic theorist that has
been repeatedly proven to
be more damaging to people of lower
circumstance uh Revenue circumstance
than to people of higher circumstance
and to penalize someone for being
successful is
not a policy which in governmental
entity should engage in which any
governmental agency should
engage all that does is suggest to
people two Alternatives don't be
successful or
cheat so I would suggest
that
reinstituting the indd tax which is a
passive tax based upon wealth that's
already been taxed and set aside
into um a Development Fund is a form of
double taxation because it's money
that's profit it's already been paid
you've already paid a tax on it and now
you're being paid a tax
on the work that that money is being is
doing and when it's put into an
investment
account to earn extra dividends or
interest it's actually being used by
either a bank in the case of Interest or
in the dividends by an investment firm
to create jobs and business
opportunities and to fund uh
developmental projects elsewhere
so it just seems to
me that of the regressive taxes talked
about this is part the indd is
perhaps worse than
most
others thank you Mr
chair okay before we go down a hole of
too much um
uh partisan Theory and and eat up too
much time I just want to um we can I
mean I'll take a couple more comments
but uh I you know we we've got to be
efficient with this discussion um I
think to representative pl's point in
the beginning um you know we have had a
bunch of changes over the past year um
and it may be time to let things settle
um as opposed to um you know M making
any new changes I think on as he pointed
out on the tax uh side um you know we're
we're kind of trying to let things
settle see how things go and this may be
another one in a non-budget year um to
to do the same so with that that last
comment I'll I'll take for the chair
just point of order yeah um are we
thinking um these may go to interim
study as an
option it's it's a possible option it
just seems like when we're this far
apart um that that might be a good
solution for both types of bills so
because we could do this discussion
really a long long time right so I just
want make sure cuz it hadn't really been
mentioned what we were going to vote on
but you know that seems to be a nice
Middle Ground between OTP and itl the
interim study it also would give us time
to see what's going on around us and I
with these different lawsuits and so on
right I just a thought I just wasn't
clear so that's thank you for thank you
for bringing that up I I'm not going to
commit to that right this minute because
the coxes have to meet um during our uh
at lunchtime we'll have a little bit
longer lunch so that you can have lunch
and and caucus and uh but I think that's
something that could be on the table
thank you for that comment comment yes
representative
lley thank you Mr chair I appreciate the
efforts to slow down too much change at
once just want to make a comment that
the change has been in One Direction um
that what we have the work that we have
done uh as a house has been in the
direction of cutting taxes in
unpredictable and I would dare say
drastic and across the across the board
ways right it's not just indd tax that's
been cut um so I would say that if if
we're arguing for a middle ground um
let's be honest with what is middle and
what is going in One Direction so I feel
like the proposal on the table is
actually to
moderate um some of the changes that
have been made so I just want to remind
us you know to kind of when people are
um speaking from ideology and not from
math that there is a mathematical middle
ground that exists that we can all look
at the math and see okay we've cut this
much tax we can predict that you know
this has been the change so let's just
keep in mind what is what moderate or
what middle of the road is thank
you representative fellows just one
really small comment on a little just
one little section of it is when there
were discussions about repealing the
interest in dividends tax one of the
arguments made was that seniors living
on a fixed income and a little bit of uh
money from dividends and interest were
impacted but this bill while it's
probably 95% the same as the old
interest in dividends tax this one has
much higher thresholds so I believe the
threshold here is um
7,500 but for seniors it could be um um
whatever 50% more than that is and I
believe correct me if I'm wrong that um
the in interest in dividends tax Port
the threshold was 2,000
2400 thank
you okay um unless someone has some burn
um okay represent Aly will yeah I just
wanted to do a little history lesson uh
before my time on before World War II uh
the state was having great difficulty
figuring out how to fund the
basic uh necessities of government and
it was
depending uh quite heavily I don't think
any more heavily than we are now frankly
uh on a property tax because that was
what the people who set up the
Constitution did but in their case the
property tax was a tax on productive
property it was not a tax on
unproductive property which included
people's
residences um and I'm not sure when it
got transferred over but um what the
Supreme Court did was to take apart the
Constitutional requirement that
everything be reasonable not Equitable
reasonable and
proportional uh on in addressing the
burden taxable tax burden of the
individuals and SE and say that we could
apply that to
entities and apply that to
uh to uh different
kinds of of uh tax Target so we had we
got at that point we only had for this
we only had the road toll and it's
called a road toll because it couldn't
be a tax um they ruled that we could
have the tobacco tax they ruled that we
could have the um the interest in
dividends tax was was already there but
it was is about the only one I believe
on repres representative Aly um I
appreciate the work that you've done on
this bill I know you did a lot of work
there's a lot of detail here but but I
don't think at this hour right now
you're going to I appreciate what you're
trying to do um but I I want to end this
uh work session could I just finish that
sentence could you you can finish the
sentence thank you on they separated out
a general Tech General taxes to specific
things that we were consuming and
specific things that uh that we owned
and in doing that they created an
unequal
burden across our
state and um it was necessary to keep
things going but uh that's how we got
where we are Mr chair could I have 20
seconds I would just like like to say
that I like Tom's idea about an interim
study we got taxes coming down here
taxes wanted to
stay leave it all alone for now approach
it all next year put it all in interim
study and let's see how it plays out
thank you thank you okay I'm going to
end the um work session on hp1
1492 okay we'll open up on HB 1563
relative to the education property tax
and the authority of political
subdivisions yes representative um
Ames and this one I I wonder if we could
set this aside and and uh I think more
work is being done on this uh by the
prime sponsor representative uh fellows
and um uh so the work to be done and
we'll be better off uh hearing a
discussion of it once that work is done
and that uh would lead us I think to uh
a U coming together and and uh talking
through this bill working on this bill
um as soon as can be done but probably
uh the mon the Tuesday or Wednesday
after this coming week something like
that so that's my request defer s now
next week have a work session on it we
could do that you'd be ready wouldn't
you yeah represented fellows um yes that
that would be useful it would uh give me
more time um Dr wanted some really
technical details about how to implement
some of it and I uh have drafted
something but they'd like to move the
words to a different line and I think it
would also be an opportunity to get um
mark galello from the Department of
Education who does the adequacy Aid
distribution because when you when you
look at this bill it you know the it
repeals the Statewide property tax way
down at the end of the bill the
beginning of it reads like like a school
funding bill so I think that that would
give people the opportunity to ask
questions about how how this interfaces
with the adequacy aid
funding
representative spillsbury did you want
to yeah I would uh concur um even
without the further work that may be
done on the
drafting uh we have two bills here 1514
coming up next education committee has a
couple of bills uh they will have
executive session on February
14th and those bills will hit the house
floor on February 22nd
since these uh bills aren't under a
deadline until uh
mid-march I think we should take our
time and at least understand where the
education committee is before we really
dig into these two bills very
hard okay so pushing this off to next
week is too soon then I I think next I
would suggest that we revisit doesn't
mean we can't work on it progressively
but I would say we not attempt a
decision or an outcome on till after the
house has seen the education committee
bills on February
22nd make a
note okay any other uh comments on this
all right then we will do a another work
session in the future on uh hb15
63 yes you you haven't called this bill
but there's a second swep bill on our
list here and I would say what has just
been said applies to it as well it's
it's uh Senate it's representative
Bickford's
bill um 154 I
think oh I'm sorry did you mention
that uh I no I was going to open that as
a separate the same same idea okay if
there's nothing else then we'll close uh
on um the work session on hp1
okay I didn't expect to move through
that that quickly so um now we just now
we just well I don't know if we caught
up or not we good um okay we'll open the
uh work session
hb514 representative PL I think this
bill has Merit because uh I'm I'm not
sure that our current method of letting
people
keep excess over o o over their
education needs is entirely
constitutional but uh in the light of
the fact that there is a committee to to
look at education funding in Toto wonder
what whether this could be pushed off uh
interim studied or something until until
such time that the committee comes back
with a full
recommendation makes sense uh represent
Ames yeah representative SP spillsbury
would make the same point the uh of the
bills that uh that he spoke of that are
in education one is a bill that takes us
does the same thing as the title of this
bill says this bill does um it moves
excess funds excess
swept it moves excess swept um
to um the uh
State uh education trust fund uh both
bills do that so I again the argument is
the point is that we should defer and
hold back um as we um
um I think more or less agreed to but it
was it's just a work session on the
previous Bill
1563 representative spillsbury do you
agree that we should hold this uh the
same amount of time as uh 1563 yes very
much for the same reasons and in
sequence with the education committee's
work in mind if I could i' just very
briefly add um I am persuaded personally
that the Constitutional issue issue is
genuine I do believe that as to that
particular claim uh that the uh trial
Court's uh Position will probably be
sustained by the New Hampshire Supreme
Court um so I think that uh there's an
obligation that's facing us whether it's
this year or next year we may want we
may want to wait for the New Hampshire
Supreme Court to opine but I do think
that we need to do something about this
um I'm a co-sponsor on
1686 which is March Smith's bill before
the education committee and it does the
same thing here with the excess swept
but in a different way actually like
representative Bickford's bill it's very
clean simple straightforward so that's
as much as we need to say now I I I
think what I'm trying to
broadcast is that after February 22nd we
have a genuine work session to wrestle
with what we need to do and not just be
sort of you know um pushing it off and
how sure are you that those uh other
education bills are taken up on the 22nd
is that pretty Stone I would hesitate to
to have they were on the docket for
tomorrow they've been postponed they are
second committee bills so they must meet
the deadline for the 22nd so that will
happen on the 14th uh the question that
I can't answer is uh whether six whether
the the education committee um will
reach a OTP an itl or interim study
conclusion and that's part of what we
need to wait and find out oh that's fine
I I don't yeah we're not worried about
what that is I just just that they've
taken them up so that if we have a work
session there's something there's
something those are on deadline to hit
the floor the 22nd okay good so we'll
we'll schedule I'll schedule work
session for 1563 and 1514 after February
22nd yes representa Ames yeah I just i'
like to add one other point I I agree
that with representative
spilsbury's uh belief that this is uh
the swept law is likely to be found with
its allowance for the retention of
revenues of of excess revenues uh to be
unconstitutional by the Supreme Court
when they reach this and that's my my
point is it's just something to think of
about it is quite possible that the
Supreme Court will reach this
issue um in the
fall it may be later than that but if
they reach this issue they could uh and
if they are wise like representative
spillsbury and me and agree with us
um
then um they could issue an order and
unlike school
funding
they the order in a in in this kind of
situation which concerns a tax that is
found to be
unconstitutional they can simply order
that the tax not be collected it's uh
it's very straightforward they issue an
injunction uh in joining the uh Dr
commissioner from um issuing the
warrant uh so we could all of a sudden
find ourselves in a in
a in a uh crisis and um um I hope that
won't happen I wanted people be aware of
that possibility and um in spite of that
we might decide that it's better you
know we through this process we've just
been talking about going through might
decide that still there are too many
questions and the whole thing needs to
be resolved at once school funding and
excess swept and all that um and we're
going to delay even though there is that
danger that
will be up against it because of action
by the Supreme Court on exus we so I
just putting that out there you know
with all the uncertainties um uh it's
context to think
about thank
you okay any else any other
comments all right seeing none we'll
close the public hearing on HB
I'll open the work session on hp1
1558 and this is going to be a very easy
one uh representative PL I recommend itl
because the fish and game Department's
already instituted those fees and the
the SP sponsor came out with a letter
saying
such I got the right Bill
yes you do
um so this one um yeah this one's pretty
straightforward I think we all got the
email from representative Spain um
explaining that and that you didn't get
it um anyways it's
uh yeah he's recommending to kill it so
I don't think there's a whole lot of
discussion there um does anyone have
anything they want to say seeing none
we'll close the work session on HP
all right
um now we'll open the uh work session on
hb1 1484 relative to the current use
taxation for certain forested
lands comments
first well let's see if there's anyone
else there isn't representative
PL this bill I don't think has Merit I I
believe that the uh current use uh uh
tax is working quite well and the
concern uh when the sponsor found out
after the fact that some land up there
was uh being not uh was being a
conservation land for the purpose of uh
Mitigation Of clim for climate change
concern about drop in tax revenue
apparently that land will have a slower
Cut Rate than other land around it so I
understand the concern but that land
will event eventually have to the timber
will eventually have to be cut or it'll
fall over and so it may a be a timing
issue and that's it and we had a lot of
testimony against this
change yes representa Le
please I just want to add that it may
have some Merit in the sense that the
concern I think is valid the question
asked I think it's valid um but I don't
think that this solution is the right
solution
so I would agree with representative PL
okay representative ORS uh thank you Mr
chair yeah I just wanted to say if we
don't manage that Forest it's going to
be detrimental to the habitat and the
wildlife and so yeah I'm not for this
thank you representative fellows I I
think that the carbon credit thing is
such a new issue that um it might be
appropriate to rethink the um current
use categories to make something that
would fit with this but that wouldn't be
our job to do
it thank you representative
elme thank you um this probably should
have gone
to a environment and agriculture first
or resources and Recreation but
um the situation at the moment is that
we really have no idea whether the
concern that was voiced is likely to
start
coming and it's very probable in New
Hampshire which
for how many years about a hundred years
has been helped by the New Hampshire
Society for the protection of forests uh
to manage the lands
on is not going to
see this problem in a large way so I
think that at the moment it's perfectly
proper
to just file the warning away as a
possibility
yeah thank you um it it seems like
everyone pretty much thinks this this
bill is um not ready for prime time um
I'm going to take a quick straw poll how
many people think this should go
itl I assuming represent duet
agrees
itl okay um
so is there anything anyone else wants
to say I think it's pretty clear where
we're headed on this one all right great
we'll end the work session for 1484 I
never expected we would be moving this
fast uh what about
yeah that's next that's
next so we're on our we're on our last
bill for uh for the work session which
is hb1 1551 so I'll open the work
session on hb1
1551 relative to distinguishing between
C corporations and S corporations for
the purpose of calculating the business
profits
tax
um who would like to make the uh first
comment on this
one
oh
representative all good idea additional
uh work needs to be
done could you elaborate no I'm just
kidding
cinct yes I think that the bill amends
the wrong part of law the testimony we
heard that it affected directly the
business profits
tax and and the sponsor was surprised at
the fiscal impact uh and that's because
uh it was uh amening the wrong part of
law so I think this just is not ready
for prime
time okay representative spillsbury
the hearing was extremely
murky and uh I think what it revealed is
that questions of how you delineate a C
Corp from a sub chapter as from an LLC
permeate across many different
provisions of law so that flaw was
evident immediately when we realized it
only amends BPT and not bet as
representative PL just said but I
suspect that's only the tip of the
iceberg so if somebody thinks that this
needs to be sorted out it needs to be
sorted out in a fairly comprehensive way
um finally I think that as long as the
indd
uh tax is on its way to fa phase out
then I think that the sponsor's concern
is effectively moot or or soon to be and
as representative Aly said in the
hearing we can Rectify that problem if
indd is reinstated but until then it's
effectively moved yeah good
point anybody
else okay so again straw pole on on 1551
then uh for
itl okay
unanimous no it's not no what happened
you didn't raise your hand no I didn't
I'm a co-sponsor I'm not gonna
vote
okay unanimous among non-
co-sponsors all right
um that is I'll close hp15 51 I never
expected we're going to get through all
those in an hour I apologize uh
represent Aly for ending your testimony
I thought we were way
behind but that's that's the beauty of
this uh you never know that sometimes
the shortest things can take the longest
and the longest can be short so it's
always a always a challenge all right so
at this point um you all know we have an
exe executive session starting at 1 um
this effectively gives us two hours I
know both caucuses want a caucus um and
um and also have lunch so we have two
hours we'll be back promptly at one
thank you Mr chairman are I've got to
run to another meeting where will we be
caucusing
um we could caucus uh here yeah we'll
caucus here
yeah I don't know if we can get upstairs
or not uh we just need to set a t we're
gonna have
to I've got to call call
um the Democratic office and the
cafeteria would be too crowded H yeah
the cafeteria will be too crowded
definitely
yeah
have it until
123 Republicans will caucus at 12:30 in
this room please be
prompt
yeah
105 I'm going to open the exec session
on cacr 18
and I'm going to recognize
representative PL for a motion yes I
move to itlc
a18 do I have a second second second by
representative
Aly
discussion representative plat the
reason I'm moving to itl is since our
country was founded we've uh given tax
exemption
to churches um and uh they they provide
a very useful uh service in in uh
welfare and and taking care of the uh
people who needed poor and indent um and
uh regardless of denomination they're
all doing that benefit this could kill
them a lot we're already the least CH
state in the nation and this would uh
drive a lot of out of existence and the
government would have to pick up that
cost eventually and if some people
people quote well this refer to the
separat of church and state there is no
such thing the first amendment gives the
churches the freedom of religion but
does not so government stays the heck
out of it but that but uh the church is
are free to do uh what what they wish
and they are providing a very useful
service that's it thank
you represent Alman I'd like to add to
that that we give tax exemptions to an
awful lot of other nonprofits and that
would bring this into
question you couldn't hear me you got to
get closer to the
mic I'm too
short we we give tax exemptions to an
awful lot of nonprofits that are not
churches and this would raise the
question of whether anybody should have
a tax
exemption anybody else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the
role representative J janigian yes
representative Edwards yes
representative erery yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL the clerk votes yes
representative Mooney yes representative
sodi yes represent ores yes represent
roord yes represent Aly yes represent
Ames yes represent Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shanberg yes representative fellow yes
represent Bolton yes representive
elberger yes representative leapley yes
represent Smith yes the vote is 20 to
zero any objection to putting that on
consent or can actually can
Constitutional Amendments go on consent
would be a question
well we can check we'll check with the
clerk on that let's no I won't check
that out yeah we'll check on that okay
I'll close the executive session on cacr
18 we'll now open the exec session on HB
1191 and recognize representative PL for
a
motion I move ought to pass on HB 1191
I'd like to speak to my
motion okay do we have representative
Southworth representative Southworth
seconds it and uh would you like to
speak to your motion yes I have to catch
up with this
paperwork
uh this is a wash to the state uh this
meels and wheels program it now works so
that uh the restaurant uh bills
$13 uh to the state that includes a tax
and uh the the recipient older folk I'm
one of them uh pays a the T tip there uh
three or $ four do tip and they're
supposed to put in $4 to the state uh as
a
contribution uh but uh the the uh this
would change the
$13 uh be to $12 because it would
eliminate the interested dividends tax
uh that Ms and wheels picks up but on
the other hand Ms and wheels turns
around and builds the state for for this
money um and so they'll be building $12
instead of $13 so the dollar loss by the
state is made up by the state so it's a
it's a wash and it helps the
program thank you representative fellows
um I'm just want to say that I'm not
sure that's accurate about um a cost um
wash for the state because I believe
that this money is all federal
money or ex except for it's Federal
money except for the um the tax
part M&R tax you're talking about I
think I think no you know I think the
federal government is paying that tax
also the whole voucher I believe is
federal
money representative El me I don't know
that this makes a difference that this
makes a difference to her objection but
I looked into it and there is a small
Federal match that we have to
provide just I I wasn't making an
exception I was just trying to get an
accurate
statement okay represent of Southworth H
thank you just to clarify it's the meals
and rooms
tax not interest in dividends my
apologies for misspeaking it is meals
and rooms I didn't yeah I didn't catch
that okay thank
you all right saying nothing else I'll
ask the clerk to call the role for um
the motion being
OTP I'll be
ready
all
right represent of
jigan yes represent uh Edwards yes
represent
erery uh yes representative duet yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative roord yes representative
Aly yes represent Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
represent shanberg yes represent fellows
yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes represent
Smith yes 20 to
zero all right the vote being 20 to zero
any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
consent
we'll now close the executive session
for HB
1191 next up we'll open the exec session
for HB 1254 and I will represent I will
recognize representative
ORS thank you Mr chair I make a motion
that we itl this
legislation I think the bill
inappropriately delegates taxing
Authority away from the
states
do I have a
second second
okay
discussion representative
Aly um the municipalities already have
the right to
collect um fees for
automobiles
um
and and they
keep proportions of various other fees
for their
expenses and I don't see that this would
be materially different from
that other
discussion uh representative Southworth
yes I think um this bill does still need
a little more work and probably an
amendment um so I'm not sure I'm you
know ready to do an up or down vote on
it because I I think it needs a little
more from the information we got at the
hearings um there are some changes that
need to be made but I'm not sure I'm
ready to itl it thank
you represent El me and I would just
like to add to that that when we left
this morning the idea is that we would
have that time to improve the bill
particularly the questions of what is a
hotel and
um and the amendment that was brought in
already on saying what the Caps would be
on being allowed to do
this I don't believe that was this
morning that was uh yesterday we
discussed 1254 representative
Ames yeah I just want to add my voice to
the
uh belief that I had that we'd have time
to consider amending this and uh
improving it I think we all felt there
were uh parts of it that needed
Improvement and um we didn't I F I
understood we hadn't finished with that
discussion and um would much prefer that
we defer rather than uh go into a
definitive vote at this time if that's
possible
um I don't yeah I don't remember that
specifically does um does anyone
remember um anyone else 1254 I don't
remember what whether we were going to
uh defer that or not representative ORS
yes I have in my notes here that it
needed work as has been stated by uh
representative ases and that uh maybe we
would bring this forward again in fy2
but that's what I have in my
notes I I think I thought my
understanding also was that this might
be something for the future but it w
there was a lot of uh there was
discussion on how it was a fairly
complex to figure out how best to do
this without uh
causing
um issues between local and and state
taxation um that was my understanding
that was more like let's bring it up
next year as opposed to let's talk about
it again here but I may be mistaken
representative Aly yes I'm I I uh
Perhaps it is that it was how it was
reported to me I thought that I remember
discussing that this
morning and the conclusion being but
since I couldn't be here yesterday um I
may have
um uh I may be representing something
that I thought was said
today or or yesterday actually uh yeah
representative PL I remember it the way
representative ORS does but having said
that uh it wouldn't bother me at all if
representative ORS changed to an interim
study from an itl so it could come up
next
year I'm I'm not sure that's what they
were
saying there is no
next right there's no effect on next
year right representative rord yes thank
you Mr Speaker and I I um so I I have
some notes that I made too as well and I
think it goes back to the issue and I
think it's a valid issue I me the Val
the issue is that some towns are being
uh under being strained more than others
yet they're not getting their fair share
of in my opinion the meals and rooms tax
and and I think that the issue is far
more complex than
um than the the rather simple approach
that 1254 has so you know BAS on the
notes that I had I I thought I was on
the understanding that you know there
was some consensus here that we believe
that there is an issue here that there
is some some meet here but perhaps next
year being a budget year would be the
more appropriate time to discuss that
and and and you know that being said
just I mean I I believe there there
needs to be a solution to this um but I
don't think 1254 does it and I don't
think this is the right time to do it so
um that's that's the recollection that I
had and I wasn't here I was running in
between meetings this morning but unless
something was said otherwise this
morning that's where I'd left it in my
notes um well 12:54 we discussed on um
yesterday not
today so so you were yeah we didn't yeah
we didn't say anything else about it um
I we also did a straw poll and of the 14
members that were here yesterday it was
seven to seven and it crossed party
lines there was no um distinction there
so I I I do remember it is this is
something that needs work and perhaps in
the next legislature but I could be
wrong yes represent fellows um yes I I
remember part of the discussion for
yesterday and one of the things point
that I made yesterday is that this bill
has appeared before but um not at at
Ways and Means I heard it heard this
bill presented maybe it was two years
ago at Municipal and County and that
they
my recollection is it was not well
received and it obviously didn't pass so
I think that's another part
of maybe why it needs to just go interim
study and get some input from Municipal
and County because it's not an issue
that's related just to Ways and Means
and it's really it's it's ways it's
money for for the um the towns not the
state anyway so I think Municipal and
County really needs to have some kind of
um input on this
bill
um so we yeah let's see our motion our
that that straw poll was on um itl I
believe but um certainly we could
um uh represent or your your motion was
itl yes represent Ames I think the sto
was
whether one would support an
OTP that's my my my note on that and I
agree with you it was 7 to S to s 7 to
seven yeah yeah let me just I don't know
we're all bad note takers chairman we
seem to be all over the place on this
particular one
uh yeah and I just wrote straw Paul I
didn't write the the motion so yes so I
don't I don't want to be repetitive but
in our discussion yesterday I was
certainly trying to tie this issue which
is
genuine to the meals and rooms um
discussion and suggesting that uh there
is a different approach with a local
search charge that could be fashioned
for
2025 in the context of meals and rooms I
don't see a solution that we can drive
to this year in the context of the fee
the way the bill is drafted I agree with
representative fellows I don't think
that this committee should take any
further action on this bill as
drafted
okay any further
comment
representative
Aly yes I am really sorry that I was
totally incapable of being here
yesterday
um because I think that there might have
been more added to the discussion but
um this I agree that the bill as it came
out
um because of the four days that we were
given to submit bills uh there was a lot
of cases where people got away with
putting in alternate versions of a
bill on that were almost the same and
people got together as in the case of
this bill and decided that um one person
was going to have the bill and that
person was someone who hasn't dealt with
this over the 15 20 years it's been
discussed
uh and um there's
definitely an issue isue in terms of of
fairness
to to um different kinds of
municipalities in this state about this
I would hate to see the rooms and meals
tax um done any other way it would
really mess up a bunch of small towns um
but uh this provides another option for
it on we were going to provide a final
amendment by next week but um if you
want to do it today then I'll just I'll
just be voting
against thank
you representative
Edwards just just a question of
clarification I think uh representative
omy didn't wasn't there a very similar
Bill to this four years ago in ways and
means and and kind of the second
question is if there was a suggestion
this went that this committee kept it an
interim study wouldn't you still need to
get all your work done and completed
before a crossover to the
Senate no if we go in if we go interim
study it's we're moving it on it's going
to move
on okay yes representative
ering yes if I think I have the
parliamentary positioning correct you
have a motion on the floor so we need to
discuss the motion or the motion needs
to be withdrawn to take any other action
so it goes over to uh whether or not we
want to hold this a week or not hold us
a week um
and I think as part of the discussion we
can ask that
question okay yes I'm I'm willing to
withdraw my motion and make a a new
motion
there's there's two there's two things
we can either make a new motion
is or we can hold this a week because
the
um um minority member has suggested that
uh there's an amendment that may or may
not be
appropriate okay
um and you believe that your Amendment
solves the
problem of fairness between
towns this is a as someone else said
this is a partial solution of that
problem which is a lot bigger that we've
got uh municipalities that act as Urban
hubs for all the municipalities around
them and provide the social services
nonprofit profit not taxed with the
property tax uh and the um and take care
of the traffic
and and the criminal aspects of uh huge
numbers of people
concentrating into that town every day
um but what is it solving what what
which do not uh which only have except
for a little bit of car tax uh
we do not have uh the property tax
for for 35,000 in Lebanon we have the
property tax for 14,000 or 15,000
whichever we are now uh in
Lebanon representative
ellerie it appears as though in out of
Comedy I would suggest that uh this
particular motion be tabled until the
next executive session and be taken up
at that point at the point we're at now
which then would allow the minority uh
leader to present her Amendment and we
can continue the discussion in that
fashion if that would be acceptable to
the uh membership of the committee yes
represent Aly perhaps I could say that I
sent an amendment of the hotel language
off to the three sponsors last night and
I've only got word back from one of them
so far okay uh yeah well you do have a
question over there well I don't know if
it's a followup to this I was going to
ask if it was appropriate to Second um
representative oler's motion to table
yeah I I that would that was my I would
a motion to table this until the next
next executive meeting well we we don't
we don't have to table we don't have to
table representa
um ORS can just withdraw his motion and
then we'll bring it up another time but
I have
go all
right um I I think given this discussion
do you want to withdraw your motion Mr
chair I withdraw my motion to IDL second
withdraws all right then we will take
this up uh on our next um at our next
meeting which will
most likely be Tuesday of next
week okay so I'll close the exec session
on
um HP
1254 okay we'll now open the exec
session on hb15
15 and representative spillsbury would
you like to make a motion yes thank you
Mr chairman I move uh itl on hb1
1515 do I have a second I'll second that
Mr
chairman shamberg uh seconds the motion
and representative spilsbury would you
like to speak to your
motion yes thank you briefly um I think
we reached General agreement in our work
session that this is a good bill to
readdress in a budget cycle and that
it's not timely for this year okay any
other
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the role when he finishes
writing I just finished perfect uh
representative janigian yes
representative Edwards yes
representative erery yes represent set
yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative
Mooney she's not here oh okay uh not
voting uh representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
roord yes representative Aly
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellow yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes represent
Smith yes okay 19 to zero one not
voting
okay uh this um can go on consent unless
uh somebody objects seeing no objections
we'll put it on
consent okay we'll close the uh I'll
close the executive session on HP
1515 I'll now open the exec session on
hb14
992 and represent and um ask
representative Al me to make a
motion you mean uh I'm doing 1492
first U I move interim study on HB
um given that it is not a budget
year h
oh right and I asked briefly to speak to
my motion sorry uh do I have a
second second by representative
ery and would you like to speak to your
motion representative Aly oh uh
basically it's that this is not a budget
year the next budget year is likely to
be very
fraught but um it is one of the items
that would be coming
back thank you any other
comments okay seeing none the clerk will
take the role one second yeah and on uh
interim
study of HB
1492 motion
okay uh representative janigian yes
representative Edwards yes
representative erery yes representative
ducet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly yes represent of Ames yes represent
of Southworth yes represent of Malloy
yes represent shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes vote is 20 to
zero okay the vote being 20 to zero any
objections to the consent calendar
seeing none we'll put it on
consent and I will close the executive
session on hb1
1492 we'll now open the exec session on
hb1
1422 and
recognize represent PL
representative
PL uh I move interim study
for uh
uh for 1422 FNA
local I'll second that Mr chairman okay
second from representative shamberg and
would you like to speak to your motion
representative PL soon I get caught up
on the paperwork
yes this
is yes uh this right for interim study
for the same reason that uh
representative Aly uh uh said in in the
previous bill this is not a budget year
we we're $100 million roughly in Surplus
but that could disappear it's too early
and so next year when we're going
through budget we have a firm handle and
what happened with revenues the last
couple of years we can talk tax changes
at that time U up or down and uh of
course uh any changes we we we should
make or should be incremental to see
what the impact is over time when
revenues you don't want to be drastic
either way in my view so that but bu
budget year is much better than
now other
discussion okay I'm seeing none the
clerk will take the role on interim
study of HB 1492 and I'm sorry 1422 and
the clock is way behind in the paperwork
so just give me a
second nobody wants this drw it can have
it huh we appreciate what you're doing
representative Platt all right and I
have to write down substitute so I don't
embarrass myself yeah take your
time problem with ways and means there's
no good jokes
just well I'll find a way yeah and I'm
kind of
mean
anyway uh going on representative
janigian the motion is to interim study
representative janigian yes
representative uh Edwards yes
representative oler yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes represent sod
yes represent ORS yes represent of rord
yes represent of Aly yes represent of
Ames yes represent of Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes represent of
shamber yes represent fellows yes yes
represent Bolton yes represent elberger
yes representative leapley yes represent
Smith yes 20 to
Zer the vote being 20 to zero uh any
objections to
consent saying none it will go on the
consent
calendar and I will close the exec
session on hp1
1422 next
is next is uh an exec session on HB
1531 and I'll open that
now and repres and recognize
representative spillsbury for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl on hb1
1531 I'll second that Mr chairman second
by representative shamberg and
representative spillsbury would you like
to speak to your
motion yes so HB
1531 uh relates to the bonus
depreciation uh provisions of section
168 uh K of the Internal Revenue code um
which is itself a moving Target and so
given the gradual phase out to zero of
that Federal program it's the wrong time
to adopt it in New Hampshire so we will
just simply stick with the 2018 Internal
Revenue code which incorporates the
phase out
thank you any other
comments okay seeing none the uh clerk
will take the role
on itl the motion of itl on hp1 1531 the
motion being itl representative janigian
yes representative
oler representative
Edwards yes representative erery yes
representative duet yes representative
spillsbury yes representative plos yes
representative Mooney yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative mooy yes representative
shamberg yes representative fellow yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative
Smith yes 20 to
zero
again the vote being 20 to zero uh any
objections to
consent seeing none this will also go on
the consent
calendar next and we will close
the executive session on
HB
1531 we now open the exec session for
hp5 33 and represent and recognize I
will recognize representative roord
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion
ought to pass on HB
1533 second that motion Mr
chairman second by representative
Schamberg and representative roord would
you like to speak to your motion yes
thank you Mr chairman current uh tax
code New Hampshire tax code regarding
business profit tax allows a safe harbor
uh uh for substantiating the value of um
services for Proprietors Partners LLC
members and an automatic Safe Harbor up
to
$75,000 this has not been updated since
2011 so um this bill changes that to
$100,000 but more importantly it links
the safe harbor to the Consumer Price
Index so hopefully we don't get in this
situ sitation
again thank you any other
comments seeing none we I will ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
OTP on HP 1533 representative janigian
yes representative uh Edwards yes
representative oler yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ores yes representative rosit yes
representative Aly yes representative
Ames yes represent of Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes represent shanberg
yes representative fellow yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes 20 to zero
we're a broken record in this committee
it's a good way it's great that we're
all in such agreement it's a it's a nice
day um any objections to
consent seeing none this will also go on
the consent calendar and I'll close the
exec session on HP
1533 and now open the exec session
on and the clerk probably wishes I'd go
a little bit
slower go ahead
I'll I'll open the exact session on HP
and I will recognize representative
ORS thank you Mr chair I make a motion
out to pass on HB
1536 I'll second that Mr chairman you're
getting good at
that what's that sir you're getting good
at that yes that'll be the last
one and representative um ores would you
like to speak to your motion yes Mr
chair
this legislation would increase the
limit will increase the limit from
$500,000 to a million dollar for assets
put into the service after I believe
it's January or I'm not sure what is the
date exactly when would that go would it
start in uh July 1st of 24 last raised
in
2015 no it would go to affect the next
the next year it wouldn't be it's not a
appropo to 2024 January 1st 2025 2025
correct um and it and it brings it more
in line with the IRS code um which is
represent spilsbury you may remember it
was I know we keep asking it was 1 point
for 2023 adjusted to a million 160
million 160 okay um and we will be at a
million which will be a little bit lower
than that but closer uh in alignment to
that representative
uh Aly I think I'm going to be
the the
uh one vote against this
but this was put into a the
500,000 was put into effect and it was
increased at that point from 100,000
which had been in
2010 I think it is no 20 um
before that um
and on
it we've only got inflation up to the
end of 2023 but um but 500,000 is
69,000 in in today's
money
uh and it it just seems like it's quite
a large leap and we always have been
below the federal government on these
things and I see no justification in
bringing us up to them when we're facing
an uncertain Revenue future and expenses
future next
year okay any um any other
comments uh I guess I'll just say um in
answer to that represent Al me I know we
talked about this um at another time but
the question is if if you're just
looking at pure inflation I would agree
with you but the question is whether the
limit was correctly identified in the
first place and now you know being
closer to the federal but still staying
below it and reset it so the federal
bounce is higher we're not a
automatically being pulled higher we're
at least uh staying in one spot
um did you want to say anything else or
anyone
else I would like to know who made the
motion I was doing something else the
motion was made by representative ORS
and seconded by representative shamber
okay and the motion is OTP on HB 1536
and seeing no more desire
for uh communication I will ask the
clerk to call the role represent jigan
yes representative Edwards yes represent
ol uh yeah I didn't hear yes yes thank
you representative du yes representative
spillsbury yes representative PL votes
yes representative Mooney yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes in spite of rep vote Yes repres
representative roord yes representative
Aly no representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative
fellow
no representative Bolton yes
Representative elberger
no Representative leapley
no representative Smith
yes voted 16 to
four all right so this um this will not
go on consent yeah because there are
four of
us
um who's doing the minority are you
going to do The Minority Report repres
sure okay unless one of you wants to do
it represent I'll May will do the
Minority
Report I'll now close the exact session
on hb1
1536 uh the next two listed on the um on
the schedule here are HPB 1563 and hb514
uh two education bills um given the um
the fact that there are other education
bills in the education committee and um
we've decided we decided during work
session to hold off uh until those go
through uh their process and then we'll
come back to these so I am not going to
exec 1563 and
1514 given that we are now down to HB
1558 I'll open the exec session and
recognize representative
sodi thank you the motion is itl on 1558
do I have a
second second represent Oli seconds it
representative sodi would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes um as
indicated To Us by uh chairman Spain at
fishing game this bill is no longer
necessary thank
you other C thoughts comments re elme
your microphone is on is that to speak
okay all right um then seeing no more um
hands I will um ask the clerk to call
the role on it all for hp15 I wish
people would talk most so it give me a
chance to catch up with the paperwork
we're trying to test how good a clerk
you really
are you're doing you're doing great
you're doing
great I I think I'm there um yes uh on
itl 1558 represent
janigian yes representative Edwards yes
representative erery yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes uh
representative sodi yes representative
Oris yes representative rord yes
represent of Aly yes representative Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamber yes representative fellow yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes the vote is 20
to
zero okay any objections to consent
seeing none we will put that on
consent um I think
can but if you're going to expend money
it it needs to go forward is that not
correct Mr
chair thank you yes so because it's itl
there's
no
uh because it's itl there's no need um
to um to not put it on consent okay um
we I'll close the exact session on hb1
1558 we now open the exact session on HB
1484 and I'll
recognize representative ORS for a
motion thank you Mr chair in order to
slow things down a little bit I want
representative PL to know the lobotomy
shows no results out here he's doing a
fine
job hb14 84 I make a motion to
itl I'll okay do I have a second I'll
second that Mr chairman for the outdoor
person over here
okay second by representative shamberg
and representative ORS would you like to
speak to your motion yes Mr chair I'd
just like to say that current use laws
in the Northern woods it's so good it's
copied by other states and I see no
reason to take this forward as an itl
thank you
did you say did I misunder what did you
just say do I you don't see a need to
take I'm saying I I I don't I want to
itl this yes okay yeah I think the way
you said it it was like a double
negative okay uh representative PL I
would add that the concern from the
author was lack uh because of a Slowdown
in cutting lack of a loss of Timber tax
I think that's simply timing not to loss
through the life of the because they'd
have to come down or rot so they will be
cut the revenue will be there just on a
slower schedule than the the author had
anticipated anybody
else okay seeing seeing none uh the
clerk will call the role for itl on HB
1484 representative janigian yes
representative Edwards yes represent
oler yes repres duet yes represent
spillsbury yes represent PL votes yes
represent Mooney yes represent sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
rord yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamber yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
represent leapley yes representative
Smith yes 20 to zero
everybody okay with
consent it appears so so we'll put that
on
consent okay get right as cramp
here coming a delay just a second would
be
nice R out of these we have one we have
one more Bill left coming up for exec
session and I'll let the clerk get a
little organized we have we have uh i r
ran out of a form ran out of forms uh
oh I need the uh exact session
form did you yeah not the roll
call all right so he he figured out how
to get himself a break but running out
of
forms I'm G to do that more
often
that's
true
I have a question yes um so when we get
into March do you think we're going to
be meeting on Mondays and
Tuesdays
um I don't know yet do you have a
preference no I just in terms of trying
to coordinate to get somebody from the
Department of Education to come in um
when we're doing the two bills about
this Statewide property tax just to kind
of give them you know I know it's not in
the calendar yet but just to give them
some kind of idea of when that will that
will be in March for sure because we
want to get past the 22nd uh and then
the final the week of the 26th we're um
going to observe the school vacation
week and not have anything so it's going
to be the March um I believe actually uh
I can tell you that I think March 4th we
will not have a meeting
yeah I'm unavail I have conflicting
commission meeting and some other stuff
happening on Monday the 4th so we will
meet March 5th and 6th I just can't tell
you what just just to you know try to
coordinate with them you think so we
probably would I mean I guess we would
probably do the education bills on on
the 5th probably five or six March five
or sixth it's definitely probably fifth
or sixth and we probably could do it on
the 5th
let me make a note though so if you're
gonna are you GNA be telling them that
now or Cas you know the person from
education might be not available and
plus he he spends a lot of time with the
education committee so okay then why
don't why don't you the thing I know
right now is it's going to be the fifth
or the 6th so you could yeah okay thank
you yes representa leapley excuse me um
just to clarify that's a Wednesday yes
because I cancelled an appointment I had
before I rescheduled for that day March
6 is a Wednesday right yeah and we are
meeting that day yeah okay thank you
most likely meeting that day I mean
because
well we're not going to meet Monday um
March 4th um it's going to I mean I
would think yes there's a
strong possibility it would be the fifth
in the six CU I we generally would need
both those days so I think you can be
pretty
sure and I'll try to when I have the
schedule worked out just like I did with
February uh last week I gave you the
pretty much the rundown for February
I'll try to do the same with March as
best I can
so I
guess I should say that I think everyone
here appreciates your efforts to make
the schedule work for as many people as
possible in a thank you you know
reasonable way we do appreciate
that all right are you all sent okay all
right I'll open the exec session on HB
1551 and recognize representative
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman I move
itl on hp1
1551 represent sham are you a second yes
Mr chairman I will second that he's
getting so good at it we might as
well and uh representative spillsbury
would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you um the sponsor was
trying to address a um past problem with
the potential of double
taxation uh regarding sub chapter S
corporations and uh yet
the fact that the um interest in
dividends tax is being phased out and
will soon disappear would moot that
problem
furthermore we it became apparent that
the bill had addressed only the business
profits tax and not the business
Enterprise tax so it wouldn't actually
solve the problem without some Amendment
and it further revealed that there are
maybe deeper uh issues in review that
could be done about how we distinguish
uh uh C corpse from sub chapter S so the
bill is not needed at this time and a
further review could be done at the in a
future
session thank you any other comments
questions
concerns okay seeing none the clerk will
take the role of the motion of itl on HP
1551 represent janigian yes represent
Edwards yes representative
erery yes representative duet yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Mooney yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes represent fellos yes
represent Bolton yes represent elberger
yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes 20 to
zero R
itl
consent okay no objections so it will go
on
consent and I will close the exact
session for
hp15
51 that concludes uh today's business I
thank everyone for their participation
cooperation uh it's it's a great day
when you've got 10 bills that went uh
209 to zero and uh we did well thank you
everyone and as far as our next our next
meetings it'll come out obviously in the
next calendar but uh as per the schedule
I had given you before we will meet on
the 13th and the 14th next week that's
Tuesday and Wednesday probably at 10:
but you'll see that in the calendar the
exact times coming out any other any
questions before you have one how did
you want to handle uh the reports oh
good question yes the reports um I'd
like to get these if we can into the
upcoming calendar which means that I
would need them
by by noon well no the the the speaker
the other day may maybe you missed the
that meeting but uh the speaker was
truly insisting that the people writing
reports not leave the room until they've
written their report yeah
well he's trying just just to let you
know okay yeah I did miss that meeting
what's that he's trying to he wants to
get as many in as possible so um given
that the speaker wants as many of these
in as possible I probably need I mean if
you if you it's only 2 o'clock we did
very well so if you can stay and write
it now I will stay and wait for it um do
we need to write a report if it's going
on consent yes okay still needs a report
I still need to review it um so I guess
I would ask people who are writing
reports to stay and write them now and
if you have a concern or can't do that
come see me you won't read my writings
I'm G to go home and type them up I'll
be done today
okay I do
not okay yeah we can we'll get we'll get
paper all right if you anyone has any
questions on that or concerns come see
me
please can
I